okay. I hope you're sitting down for this
one Republican Senator Lindsey Graham compared
Donald Trump's speech about Iran yesterday.
The one in which Trump answered no questions
about are we leaving Iraq? The one where there
were no questions answered about what is the
legal justification for assassinating Kaseem
Solemani the speech were Donald Trump's sniffed
85 times that speech Republican Senator Lindsey
Graham says was like Ronald Reagan speech
demanding that Gorbachev tear down the Berlin
wall. Um, is this the most ignorant person
you've ever seen or the most malicious? That's
my question to you. Let's take a look at what
Lindsey Graham had to say on Fox news about
Donald Trump's speech. But here's the good
news. The president made a very bold decision
today to allow things to calm down. This speech
will be talked about
long after his second term. This is on par
with tear down this wall, mr Gorbachev. This
is resetting the relationship between the
world and Iran, just not the United States.
The president said there's an evil empire
in Iran that's been owned, destroying the
world, uh, killing the people in Israel and
coming after us and now will no longer tolerate
it. So this is on par with Reagan's tear down
this wall speech.
This speech will not be talked about long
after Donald Trump's second term. So let's
actually compare. Here's the moment that Lindsey
Graham is referring to of Ronald Reagan speaking.
There is one sign the Soviets can make that
would be unmistakable. That would advance
dramatically the cause of freedom and peace.
Mr Gorbachev open this gate.
[inaudible]
mr Gorbachev tear down this one.
that speech Lindsay Graham says was like Trump
yesterday, which sounded like this
over the last three years under my leadership,
our economy is stronger than ever before in
America's achieved energy independence. These
historic accomplishment shades, our strategic
priorities. These are accomplishments that
nobody thought were possible.
Yeah. Here's another clip of the speech that
Lindsey Graham says was Ronald Reagan, like
your campaign of Tara murder, ma'am will not
be tolerated any longer. It will not be allowed
to go forward. Today I am going to ask dado
right, so something is maybe wrong with Lindsey
Graham or his malignant Brown nosing has metastasized
and by the way, it sort of sounds like I'm
granting that the Reagan speech was a great
speech. I'm not even saying that it just clearly
bore no resemblance to Donald Trump's speech
whatsoever between the lies and the sniffing
and the irrational port foreign policy and
again, Donald Trump spending what a quarter
a third of the speech implicitly or explicitly
blaming Barack Obama for his own screw ups
and miscalculations the Reagan tear down this
wall speech. Interestingly enough, just to
address it momentarily was a very opportunistic
speech in the sense that the cold war was
already clearly nearing its end and Reagan
saying, tear down this wall had very little
to do with what ultimately happened, which
was already well, well on its way, but to
compare Donald Trump's speech to that is absolutely
nonsense.
The best explanation for how to interpret
Lindsay Graham actually came from Republican
strategist, Steve Schmidt. Check this out.
Steve Schmidt previously saying, people try
to analyze Lindsay through the prism of the
manifest in consistencies that exist between
things that he used to believe and what he's
doing. Now. The way to understand him is to
look at what's consistent and essentially
what he is in American politics is what in
the aquatic world would be a pilot fish, a
smaller fish that hovers about a larger predator
like a shark living off its detritus. That's
Lindsey. And when he swam around the McCain
shark, broadly viewed as a virtuous and good
shark, Lindsey took on the patina of virtue,
but wherever the apex shark is, you find the
Lindsey fish hovering about and Trump's the
newest shark in the sea. Lindsey has a real
draw to power, but he's found it unattainable
on his own.
Merits. Could not say it better myself, and
this is a perfect opportunity to remind you
that Lindsey Graham has an opponent in 2020
Lindsey Graham is one of the a third of senators
that is up for reelection this year. Lindsey
Graham could be removed from the Senate representing
South Carolina. Jamie Harrison is his name.
He raised more than three and a half million
dollars in the fourth quarter of 2019. You
can donate to him@jamieharrison.com that's
J a M E harrison.com. We can remove this sky
and wow. Would we be better off if we were
able to do that? Make sure you're following
the David Pakman show on Instagram for more
coverage of important 2020 races that we should
be following. We are at David Pakman show
on Instagram. While you're there, give me
a follow at David dot Pacman. We've got a
great interview coming up for you next and
a little bit later in the show. I am sort
of [inaudible]
going to praise tool. See gabber. I think
you will be interested in the content and
context of that segment coming up
a
little
bit later.